sylla abdoulaye and I take the
twenties who have not had
you intervention is still necessary
because the waters are only access to
areas where it is powerful but other
currencies there is no road you
need vehicles
there  need trained personnel for near
the cad disease the problem is
the infrastructure and we say thank god
the international community has
invested in a that it is a bit to staff
but today we inaugurated a center
of  treatment built entirely
by france
I recalled that they also look at
my my commitment it is above all by
focusing on children orphans
since most are far
from school we risk having a
hole  of a generation a loss of a
generation since at this moment these
children need assistance not
only medical assistance but also
psychological assistance